here we have to accept our common
humanity you know here you and i are
talking we're different ages living in
different places
but we accept where there's a lot of
things that are common between us
because we're human beings we've got
light inside of us we've got darkness
inside of us we've got good things
happening we've got bad things happening
we've got strengths we've got weaknesses
we do wonderful things we make mistakes
and so when we can accept that common
humanity and have some self-compassion
and recognize i can have these feelings
and not be these feelings
then that's the emotional work done
then i can go back to that wonderful
phrase we used earlier which is and
what's the next action
and you can lay on top of that
implementation intentions if you want
making things concrete just getting
started and you see they have to dance
together if you don't do the emotional
work
you're not going to get to the cognitive
work because you're gone hey friends
welcome back to deep dive the weekly
podcast where every week i have the
immense privilege to speak to authors
researchers entrepreneurs creators and
other inspiring people about how they
got to where they are and the strategies
and tools we can learn from them to
apply to our own lives now this
conversation that you're about to hear
is fantastic if i say so myself it is a
conversation with professor tim pitchell
who is a retired professor of psychology
at carleton university but he's one of
the world's most foremost experts in the
field of procrastination he's written
two whole books about it he's authored
dozens and dozens of research papers
stretching back to like the 90s about
the concept of procrastination and goal
setting and motivation and essentially
all of this stuff that we love to talk
about around productivity so in the
conversation we talk a lot about what is
it that makes us procrastinate why we do
it how and what we can do about it we
talk a lot about the idea of goal
setting
and what sort of goals that we should
set to actually kind of work towards in
the most intentional way possible but we
also talk a little bit about
spirituality about tim's love of alan
watts who's a person that i've gotten
recently introduced to so i hope you
enjoyed this conversation as much as i
did i am also in the process of writing
a book about productivity and currently
working on the the middle bit which is
three chapters about procrastination so
i feel like i'm trying to absorb all the
things and it feels kind of weird
because i've been seeing your name
referenced in like research papers for
years the whole procrastination is
emotional regulation i think that's a
phrase that's often attributed
attributed to you but i didn't i didn't
know what you looked like until i
watched your youtube video talk where
that you did for tas
that's a long time ago and that was like
nine years ago or something and i was
like oh okay
yeah
phd looks like that's right then well i
watched you i i ran into you
a while back i don't know what i was
searching for but i watched you and i
really enjoyed your work i can't say
i've
uh
gone deep into all of your episodes but
i i did enjoy your your episode on
procrastination where you delve into
stephen pressfield's the war of art
because i i was introduced to that once
giving a talk to teachers and an english
teacher asked me if i read the book and
i hadn't
and i agree with you that resistance is
something very important to understand
yeah
yeah amazing so i'd love to have a chat
mostly around kind of the idea of
procrastination given that that's your
that's your field of research i guess
one place i wanted to start with with
was the idea of
procrastination versus delay what do you
mean when you say that you know
sometimes when we think we're
procrastinating we're not actually
procrastinating how do you how do you
think about the difference between those
two things i'm glad you started there
procrastination in the research
literature is defined as the voluntary
delay of an intended action despite
expecting to be worse off for the delay
so right from the beginning we define
procrastination as a type of delay
and so often when i get interviewed
especially by reporters who always want
to have a catchy title by turning a vice
into a virtue they want to show there
must be a good type of procrastination
and i get very upset about that i think
those are oxymorons like
let's just talk about different forms of
delay so to answer your question now
with that as a background
there's purposeful delay like we you and
i could have done this interview at
another time but we chose now and in a
sense we delayed it from other times
because it fit our schedules best it was
purposeful and we do that every day it's
part of being a rational agent when we
use our practical reason and all things
considered we say this is when i should
do this and it might mean i delay it and
if something else comes up that's a
higher priority we'll we could change
our minds an intention update
now there's also inevitable delay
imagine for example recently here in
canada we had a major disruption of the
internet well if that happened today
inevitably you and i would delay our
interview
so and that happens all the time the
plane travel right now is
legendary for that and and no one looks
at this poor traveler and says oh you're
such a terrible procrastinator they
understand it's inevitable
and then you can't see where i'm sitting
i'm sitting in my porch and next to me
is a picture of my father
and he died in 2016
and i loved my dad a great deal and when
he died my world stopped for a little
while and things didn't get done but not
once did i say oh tim you're such a
terrible procrastinator nor did anyone
else and we frame that as delay due to
emotional problems so there's three
right off the top purposeful inevitable
delay due to emotional problems that on
our procrastination and we need to
separate those because often in our
lives if we only have one word for delay
we end up at the end of the day beating
ourselves up when in fact it might have
been a very sagacious delay it was a
good idea to wait there i'll stop there
because i could go on forever on just
that topic but there is hedonistic delay
and and irrational delay and all these
other ones that you and i will talk
about i'm sure
yeah absolutely i guess one of the
things that we found when
when we're doing kind of research for
this is that
the
you seem to be very like procrastination
is always bad kind of vibes and in a lot
of the articles it's like some people
are trying to make the point oh but like
sometimes some procrastination is good
procrastination and we've talked about
how the idea of delay potentially solve
this this issue but i wonder
do you
one one idea i've had floating in my
mind
for some time you know
this idea of every behavior evolved from
an evolutionarily useful behavior do you
feel like procrastination has any kind
of roots in evolutionary psychology in
terms of short-termism actually
benefited us rather than long-term
planning yeah that's a very good
question a difficult one to answer i
want to take exception to your first
statement that every behavior
was adaptive somehow we could have
things that occur
that have no
function or it and more importantly in
our modern world we have this stone age
brain running around in the modern world
and so even if our ancestors there was a
reason to believe that a bird in the
hand is worth two in the bush that may
be one way we'd think about the
impulsivity that we see in
procrastination uh certainly impulsive
correlated procrastination and it made
sense just to do it just act
but i i don't think that every behavior
is that way it is adaptive there's three
things and we don't necessarily dive too
deeply into evolutionary psychology
interested listeners can go read the
work of david buss for example uh but
there are other
things can happen evolutionarily that
are are not adaptive so
is there a reason that we procrastinate
that is related to those things sure but
i think that it would have a lot to do
with the nature of reward and certainly
our emotions yeah nature of reward
and our emotions
okay so if if we knew the reward was i
guess coming up in the short term then
what do you mean by the nature of ward
well we do prefer short-term rewards i
mean some people who take a behavioral
economic view of procrastination say
it's all about
utility and they they'll frame it this
way and that we end up doing the thing
with the highest utility right now it's
a species reward in some ways because
it's it's not related to our ultimate
goal but we're getting the sooner
smaller goal reward instead of the later
larger reward and so that's one way to
frame this but
you know even as i listened to you when
you talked about stephen pressfield in
your earlier episode about
procrastination you talked about
resistance and
the reward and avoidance is very big
i liked your question about evolution
you know if we look at robert wright who
wrote a wonderful book years ago about
the moral animal and
evolutionary theory he said probably the
fundamental behavior of every organism
since the beginning of organisms has
been the choice to avoid or approach and
isn't that in some ways the simplest way
to think about procrastination and even
prestfield's notion of resistance what
does resistance lead to avoidance and
what does that avoidance do
it's a negative reinforcer
now i think it's important just to step
back for a minute for listeners to say
well it's a negative reinforcer if if
it's raining outside and i put up an
umbrella i get rid of the negative
stimulus of rain so it's a reinforcement
i get rid of a negative stimulus we call
that negative reinforcement it's not
punishment so if i avoid something
because i'm feeling this internal
resistance and you dealt with it so
clearly when you talked about
pressfield's work i'm afraid for example
i want to start a podcast but i'm afraid
it'll be a failure i want to write a new
york times bestseller but you know
what's the odds of that so it freezes in
our tracks so we avoid it and we get
rewarded because it gets rid of those
negative emotions and that in a nutshell
is what i look at in terms of when i say
that procrastination is an
emotion-focused coping strategy and
there's the reward the reward is yeah i
get rid of uh aversive stimulus
yeah that that was something that really
struck me as i was reading your book
this idea that
it feels good to procrastinate in the
moment and you're choosing to feel good
in that moment over
i guess
serve your future self
as it were and i found that idea very
interesting because i imagine you know
later tonight i've got a personal
trainer session
and you know it's you know i've
pre-committed to this paid for like 12
of them because i know it's a thing i
wouldn't want to take seriously but if
something were to come up and he would
message me being i'm so sorry i can't do
it i would feel this immense burst of
dope yes oh my god it's been cancelled i
don't have to do it this feels so good
and it's weird because i know that that
would be acting against my interest and
of course
if i were more disciplined maybe we
could talk about discipline i would
choose to work out anyway realistically
i would feel like i've
earned back an hour of my time
completely for free and it would feel
incredible and i'd it would be the
happiest thing that's happened to me all
day other than other than this
conversation with you of course so what
what's going on there like how why why
does it feel so good to
not do the thing
oh you know i think everyone had a
visceral reaction to the personal
trainer story uh it's it's a great deal
of effort it's one thing to even go for
a workout on your own because you can
put in as much or as little effort as
you
feel at the moment like you can wander
around the weight room quite aimlessly
and still say yeah i went to the gym
when you have a personal trainer you
know you're going to bust your butt
and you're going to do the extra set and
you're going to work to exhaustion
and and pass that and so
right there it it it's built in
adversity now you want it
it's serving your long-term goal but you
don't want what it means in the short
term isn't that true of so many things
like saving for the future i'd like to
have money for retirement but i i'd
rather spend the money now i'd like to
be fit i'd like to eat well but i'd like
to have the donut right now and so then
we have this compensatory thinking in
fact some of our most recent research in
the area has been looking at what
dietitians know as compensatory beliefs
and compensatory thinking
and and so in fact you think for example
oh i really want that donut well i'll
eat just a salad tonight
this commitment to later but it's always
later and that's the same thing that's
going on with procrastination and it's
the same kind of rationalization that
goes on with well i didn't cancel the
workout and you're absolutely right you
could work out we should spend more time
on that because i love the feeling that
yoga gives me stretching is just the
best thing for my body there's so many
days when i don't feel like stepping on
the mat
and but the moment i step on the mat
magic happens
so it's in that precipitous moment
of beating that resistance that you
talked about in that earlier episode
based on stephen pressfield's notion of
this resistance
and getting past it you know one of the
chapters in that book you're reading
through is just get started
now it's funny because i'm very public
like you have or i have been not
recently i haven't
and people would write to me and say
well dr pitchell you know it's really
great i could just get started but
honestly sir if i could just get started
i wouldn't have a procrastination
problem could you do a little bit better
than that for you please and i thought
oh that it's so fair right so let me go
on a little bit longer
so i had to go to the work of a product
group productivity guru you'll know very
well david allen
and he says you know we don't do tasks
we don't do projects we do actions and
the best question you can ask yourself
is what's the next action and so that's
become this old my own personal mantra
as the gateway to
just get started what's the next action
tim
just roll out that yoga mat and stand on
it
and as soon as you do that you know your
body's going to respond you're going to
lift your arms and things are going to
start to happen
so they're
a bit of a rambly answer to your
question but still on topic
it's it's great stuff one of the
i guess
you know i'm in the process of writing a
book about productivity the core thesis
is that at least for me what i found is
that the secret to sustainable
productivity has been to
find a way to
make the things that i have to do more
energizing
so that a i'm feel more productive at
doing them and b then i'll have more
energy to be able to give to my youtube
channel in the evenings or playing board
games with friends and just not being
completely drained at the end of the
workday and so the first part of the
book the first three chapters are about
power play and people essentially
autonomy mastery purpose bringing other
people getting energy from that making
it fun gamification all that kind of
stuff that generally the basic human
needs yeah yeah all of those things and
if we can find a way to apply them to
our work then hey it becomes more
energizing but then we run into that
thing of like okay i know that doing
yoga or going to the gym is going to
energize me but it's just such a
struggle to get started
and one of the things
one of the statements that i kind of
want to make in the book and i'd love to
get your take on is that really
95 to 98 of procrastination is just
about that getting started
and almost like newton's first law you
know the law of inertia as you'll be
familiar with where it's like an object
at rest will continue to stay at rest
but an object in motion tends to stay in
motion unless acted on by external
imbalance force or the idea of
activation energy and biology and
chemistry reactions where it takes a bit
of energy to get started but once the
reaction gets going then it's you know
it's unlikely to stop and it's gonna
it's gonna do the rest of its thing
to what extent do you think i guess then
that it's fair to say that to be honest
if you wanna solve procrastination just
solve the getting started problem just
like find a way to just do that take the
first step do the thing or like what
else is going on i mean it's it's fun to
want to be able to say something like 95
of the issue is this i can't tell you
that based on research
but i i know the rhetorical purpose of
that and i i would agree with you in
principle that it is the major step it's
priming the pump it and it is becoming
my personal mantra because there's every
day there'll become a point in my day
either because i don't feel i have the
energy or because the task i have in
front of me is aversive
usually a combination of both because
they play on each other the moment you
face a task you don't want
you start to
feel a waning of your energy it's a
reaction to stress as well
that i'll take you back into the 1990s
when i first started doing research on
procrastination so for a lot of your
younger listeners are going what a
geezer the 1990s really yeah i'm going
to take you back there there were no
cell phones i had to buy pagers you
probably don't even know what a pager is
right but as a physician you would so
that this i bought pagers for students i
gave them little binders and i paged
them throughout the day in psychology we
call this an experience sampling
approach and so
i'll just make up some days here because
we did it throughout quite a few months
but let's say we did it monday to friday
and on monday we'd page the students and
say what are you doing oh i'm hanging
out in the coffee shop with my friends
so how do you feel about that how
difficult how stressful how enjoyable
not surprisingly not that difficult not
that stressful pretty enjoyable is there
something else you should be doing oh
yeah yeah i should be working on my
stats assignment how difficult stressful
and enjoyable is that oh crazy difficult
crazy stressful
horribly not enjoyable you know zero so
they're rating these things from zero to
ten eleven point scale and then we ask
them what what other things are you
thinking
oh i i'll feel more like doing it
tomorrow we need to come back to that
this whole idea of future self you
mentioned
and uh i work better under pressure
these sorts of things right so we page
them throughout the week and sure enough
they keep putting things off and there's
some wonderful philosophy around this
notion from
transit of intransitive preferences here
that we let's not get carried away into
that right now we can come back if you
want but every day they put it off
now finally this assignment stress this
stats assignments due on friday thursday
night we paged them and sure enough what
are you doing working on my stats
assignment how enjoyable how difficult
how stressful the amazing thing was we
saw a statistically significant
difference in the enjoyment the
difficulty and the stress
it became more enjoyable
perceived as less difficult and less
stressful now it doesn't mean that
enjoyment was something like eight out
of ten now it just means it wasn't one
or two
and the stress and the difficulty it was
still there but it was lower in a way
that
more than you would expect by chance
alone and then when we asked them what
are you thinking
you didn't hear people spontaneously say
things like oh i'm so glad i waited till
now because i work so much better under
pressure they said things like this
isn't as bad as i thought i was why
didn't i start earlier because i could
do so so much better job on that i mean
that was a turning point for me in our
research in terms of the way i was
conceiving this now in some ways that's
nothing new like we've all experienced
that but to see it consistently across
people in a data set this way really
taught me something and so i would argue
based on just that that we delude
ourselves a lot we're really good at the
self-deception in fact john perry who's
written a wonderful little book on
procrastination if you haven't seen it
called the art of the art of
procrastination i think it's called john
perry he's a retired philosopher from
stanford
and he's written this wonderful essay on
the internet if you haven't seen it
already called structured
procrastination but john perry i won't
go into that now but we can go back to
it what he says is you know
all of this takes a bit of
self-deception but don't worry
procrastinators are very good at that
and i saw it in our research we we're
really good at saying things i'll feel
more like it tomorrow i work better
under pressure and on and on and on yeah
so back to your point you know you'd
like to write in your chapter that 95 of
it is getting started and i say yeah i
agree with you
that it really is the kingpin in this
that once you get started
uh you've you probably will keep going
because not only have we seen it change
our perceptions of the task but i would
argue that it changes your perception of
self as well
there's nothing like the downward spiral
of procrastination to make you feel like
an abject failure right that's why
what's the most
strongest emotion associated with
procrastination
guilt and if we do it for long enough
that can become shame because now we
take it as this somehow this moral
failing not just guilt for this one
action but this something about our
whole personhood
now the last thing i'd add is that other
research in social psychology
shows us that
even a little bit of progress on the
goal
fuels our well-being
and that fueling our well-being can be
what we can build our motivation on
right that it's the um
the difference then between hedonic and
eu demonic
happiness which you know i know that
your your channel here is all about
happiness and productivity and you would
know you've probably talked about
eudaimonia before
but by engaging
we find reward
and so getting started
is the beginning of that reward
long answer but one that is takes you
back into some research fantastic yeah i
really appreciate the the in-depth
in-depth answers here and also i i
hadn't come across john perry before so
i will definitely check that out and
start i found structured procrastination
i found the book perfect there's a few
terms related to the idea of
procrastination that
i have always found various different
definitions for
and there's three of them and i'd love
it if you can just riff on those three
words i guess the first is
goals
the second is discipline and the third
is motivation i guess discipline and
motivation to me feel like more related
than the idea of goals does but like how
how do you think of those different
concepts or constructs you could spend
weeks on each one of them but i'm going
to add another one because i know you've
interviewed james clear on habits
and uh or at least you've talked about
his work i would also think about an
earlier book called the power of habit
charles dude another really wonderful
book but we'll leave that to last so
goals you and i would quickly agree
we're social animals you even put that
in the first three chapters you know the
people
but we're also
goal-oriented if you think about that
last part of the brain to be added
evolutionary to make us human species in
so many ways the prefrontal cortex and
there's a story in there about
procrastination as well
it is all about
goals
inhibiting actions
short-term memory executive functions we
call it so we are a goal-oriented
species we represent our goals mentally
and we work to achieve them
so really important and in fact we
create intentions around our goals and
it's the gap between intention and
action which is the heart of
procrastination
as an aside ally i didn't do my phd in
procrastination although i
procrastinated a fair bit on the way
like many students
i would tell you now though i don't
almost ever procrastinate so i can
i'm a poster child for saying that once
you learn some things about
procrastination you can reduce it if you
want to
but
with i studied goals that's what i was
studying i was studying people's
personal projects
what they were doing and how it made
them feel
and what i turned a corner on is that
when i was doing my phd research when i
interviewed people it was the goals they
said they were going to do
projects they said they're going to do
they never did that really predicted
their well-being and if they had a lot
of those projects i knew where their
well-being was it was in the toilet so
their goals that's me riffing on goals
and there's tons and goals like you
could talk about how do you set a smart
goal you know specific and measurable
and on and on can talk about that if you
want to i don't want to
because what i want to talk about what
gets in the way you know someone can
help you set your goals someone can help
you be a better time manager and you can
still completely fail because what's
going to get in the way is
procrastination and why you do that is
everything to do with emotion focused
coping and i might talk about goals
discipline can i ask a quick follow-up
question on the goals front you're
probably familiar with pierce steel very
much i actually had a just a random zoom
call with him a few weeks ago he was he
was very gracious for this time we were
talking about procrastination
unsurprisingly something that he says in
the procrastination equation which is
his somewhat more accessible kind of
summary of the research is that he
doesn't like the idea of smart goals
because it contains too many and yet
also too few letters in that like
specific and measurable are somewhat
like redundant because it sort of means
kind of the same thing and i've
i have some i have a weird relationship
with goals in that for me for certain
goals
i get very motivated motivated uh we can
define that later uh i get very
motivated by the pursuit of numbers like
i had a dexa scan a few weeks ago to
measure my body fat percentage and
muscle mass and seeing the numbers and
having a goal to work towards in terms
of calories and training felt very
motivating and it felt great
but when i have a goal to work towards
like i want to hit 5 million subscribers
on my youtube channel which is outside
of my control at that point it starts to
feel very demotivating and i think you
know what i'd way rather have a
non-smart goal like
make a video a week and enjoy the
process or something like that rather
than a more specific like x number of
subscribers by x-date at x-time what's
the answer here or is it just like a bit
of a yeah let me back it right up to
piers comment about smart of course i
think many things that are pitched out
there in the name of productivity and
goal pursuit can be criticized but
they're not bad heuristics to work from
and i don't think we should spend a lot
of time on saying it's got two letters
too many letters are too few or that's
specific and measurable or too similar
that's not important
the
thing that you just mentioned about the
different kinds of goals you have the
one being the body fat measurement and
the goal and the other being the number
of viewers or followers
that reminds me of something you said in
an earlier podcast about inputs you'd
like to focus on
inputs and not outputs things that are
beyond your control these are sometimes
known as process versus output and so we
need to focus more on process goals i
i'm not
keen on criticizing these heuristics as
i say and at the same time i would say
that your notion of inputs is really
important here on the one hand you know
you have control over the one with body
fat it's how much you're going to
exercise the other one is
the internet here is a strange place and
you don't know what's going to go viral
and what's not going to go viral or when
you're going to say something that's
going to offend a million people right
and and so
because it's under your control then you
don't want to set a measurable goal or a
specific goal and there's even for most
people like i have a very good friend in
the netherlands and we might talk about
him later joel anderson because he's a
philosopher who writes about
procrastination and he and i often argue
about the specificity level of our goals
some people like them really specific
and some people don't it can be an
individual difference variable so there
you said you allowed me to riff i'm
riffing back on you about this notion of
what peers said about your the smart
notion and about your earlier concept of
inputs and i think you're smart to focus
on the things that you can control nice
okay we could spend a lot of time on
goals and and in fact a lot of my
colleagues do in fact and i i remind you
that's where i started my own work yeah
but what i want to talk about what gets
in the way of our goal pursuit because
quite frankly
human beings are are always in goal
pursuit what i think we have to do is
talk about what gets in the way and i
borrow that actually from brene brown
you know she's a shame researcher who
talks about wholehearted living
and when i read one of her books the
gift of vulnerability and and
a point of connection for you and me you
and i
is that uh it was i listened to it on an
audible and i know you're a big audible
fan and so am i i can remember the
moment i heard this phrase in her book i
was horses here i was crossing the creek
and the gully pat let's go over to the
pasture
and she said we have to talk about the
things that get in the way of doing what
is best for us
and i thought yeah that's where
why i'm a procrastination researcher and
i can talk about productivity and that's
why she's a shame researcher and she
talked about wholehearted living right
they they one gets in the way and so we
can talk about goals forever but and i
could help you set better goals based on
some of my colleagues research and we
don't have to use smart right we could
put that aside if if we wanted to but
there's still other things we could
learn about our goals for example i
could use the heuristic of meaning and
manageability we need goals that are
meaningful and manageable and if they're
not both you're not going anywhere right
so all of that's there
now discipline your next topic well
discipline tastes and smells like
willpower and you're going to see i have
a short chapter in that book in your
hands because it was written in 20
actually the book was probably written
in 2010 and then republished in 2013
because it was i originally published it
on my own and then penguin asked if they
could publish it
and i said sure do you want to change
anything i said no
we just changed the title and and i
didn't have anything to change at that
time but since that time that chapter on
willpower was based a lot on the ego
depletion model and it's come under
quite a bit of scrutiny and i like roy
baumeister would not throw the baby out
with the bath water there's certainly
this notion that at some points in the
day you feel depleted
but this notion of willpower and and
kelly mcgonagall's willpower instinct
you know we we know that it's it's a
very
you can't depend on your willpower and
in fact i said we could talk about joel
anderson joel anderson says
uh we we could actually outsource our
will and that's where i thought you were
going a few minutes ago
because
if i said to you what's three times
three ally you'd say nine and if i said
what's 487 times 963 you might tell me
although you might not because you're
pretty bright guy
it's called extended cognition we
interrupt this episode to bring you news
from our sponsor which is short form
this is very exciting short form is
sponsoring basically this whole season
they are by far the best service that
summarizes books that i have ever come
across and i have used all of them i
don't think i'm allowed to mention the
competitors by name but you know who the
competitors are short form is just way
better than any of them it's great
because not only do they summarize books
they give you a one page summary of the
book and then also a whole chapter by
chapter summary of the books but they
also have interactive sections where
they give you these little boxes to do
exercises and stuff so you can really
engage with the ideas in the book and
also if the author for example carol
dweck of mindset sick book by the way
but if the author says something
particularly controversial or something
that has been since um kind of updated
or someone else has done a new study
some stuff around like willpower and ego
depletion and stuff short form will put
in a little note saying by the way the
study that she cites in this book is 10
years old and actually last year a new
study came out that blah blah blah blah
and it's sick because then i don't have
to think critically about the ideas
myself short form does the critical
thinking for me and it gives me the
different sides of the different debates
for situations where there's some kind
of debate so if you like the idea of
doing that head over to shortform.com
forward slash deep dive and that will
give you 20 off the annual premium
subscription so thank you short form for
sponsoring this episode the highest
correlation between any personality
trait and procrastination is
conscientiousness
and conscience conscientiousness is
really defined by dutifulness
organization and self-discipline a
couple others but self-discipline so
some of us come into the world because
personality traits nature and nurture
we're more disciplined to begin with i'm
very much like that
very much like that and if i put
something in my calendar like i'm doing
something tomorrow at eight o'clock
that's a serious commitment and i'm
disciplined enough to show up and you go
back to steven pressfield's work that
you talked about show up right
professionals show up yeah so what do i
think of discipline
discipline can be misused because we can
always rely on internal willpower and we
should learn to outsource some of it
some of us naturally have more
discipline we're more conscientious by
nature and if you've got it use it but
don't bemoan the fact if you don't
there's lots of ways to outsource your
willpower
motivation riff on motivation
motivation should follow action not the
other way around
it's
this is huge right that
i can't i don't know where people learn
this notion that they have to feel like
it they have to be in the mood but
that's part of the procrastinator
procrastinator song i don't want to i
don't feel like it'll feel more like it
tomorrow it's as if we're waiting for
our muse
we're waiting for that
bus to come that's going to pick us up
and give us our motivation
well that bus doesn't stop here anymore
and so motivation typically follows
action and it goes back to that notion i
said earlier if we make even a little
bit of progress on our goal it fuels our
well-being and that's when we intersect
with motivation now we could talk more
about motivation if i'm riffing on it
i'd say motivation is at the
intersection of will and skill and
that's where we might bring my chicks on
the highest notion of flow for example
when my
will and my skill match and i'm
challenging myself
just a little bit beyond perhaps what my
skill level can be but i'm working hard
and i completely lose myself in i get
into that magical state of flow
and then and i use the word already
that's when the magic happens so there
me riffing on motivation motivation
should follow action
and finally i wanted to bring in the
word habit because i would say all of
these things come together with good
habits and getting a trainer like you do
for 12 weeks may well
create a new habit which is friday night
ali goes to the gym doesn't need a
trainer anymore he knows how to dig deep
on his own i guess
one thing i've been
trying to get at with this idea of sort
of making things feel energizing
is that feeling
and i'm i i guess i'm sort of thinking
about the concept
of flow here but just that feeling of
effortlessness
where
for example
you know
people always ask me how did how did you
make a youtube channel while working as
a physician and like and stuff
and
what i would do is when i would see when
i would feel like it was becoming like
too much of a chore and i would just
like sit down and do the thing i would
still sit down and do the thing but i
would at the same time be thinking about
okay cool i actually don't want this to
feel like a chore i want to in a in a
dream world i actually would enjoy the
pursuit of the goal
rather than treat it or almost coerce
myself into doing it and i haven't yet
gone to this point with personal
training like i don't enjoy the sessions
i'm glad i do them anyway but i would
love to be able to enjoy them
what do you think there's anything here
around like help helping us find the
thing that we're doing itself more fun
by
changing the way we frame it or adding
gamifications or a progress bar or any
other of the strategies that people use
to theoretically make things a bit more
fun
yes and no like is that like everything
yes we can
find we can gamification is a good way
to go like that right but
you know let's take your example because
you use yourself as an example you're a
highly intellectual guy
and so for you
i'm really impressed with what you do in
the the episodes i've watched
because there's a ton of creativity in
there like even just choosing the shots
and how you're changing things and
sometimes it's writing down and then
comes back to you
you're gifted in terms of keeping
people's attention messaging you're
articulate and so
that feeds you
partly because of who you are so you
know there's going to be a limit
to to how much you can enjoy that
compared to how much you can enjoy
working out because that may not be your
first nature let's put it that way right
it's to use a very loose expression that
you know so
there are other people who
wouldn't love the creativity of creating
the podcasts that you do but would love
to go and refine let's take tennis as an
example because i taught tennis for so
many years
a down the line slice backhand approach
shot and they'll hit hundreds if not
thousands of them right
and they do get into the flow
but what's so fascinating i'm glad you
brought in my high chicks had my highest
work on flow because flow takes effort
before you get there the effortlessness
is an outcome of a whole
lack of effort earlier
of training and discipline and focus and
then you get to a point where now the
skill and will meet and boom all of a
sudden it feels effortless but you don't
go into it thinking this is going to
feel effortless right but it feels it
can feel
better for some people based on what i'm
i'm just loosely calling first nature
and i would say your first nature is
much more intellectual
not that you don't have a strong
physique in fact no mention training
today because
when i was watching one of your videos
you were wearing a t-shirt and i watched
you move your arm and i thought yeah
that guy's got quite a bicep going on
there
and so it's obviously your training
thank you very much
well you're welcome but it was easy to
notice as we noticed things about each
other i know that i've noticed your
intellect as well
but so you took special pride in that
because you're working harder at that
where is
intellectual stuff i bet you since
you've been a little guy it just it just
comes out of you right it's not hard
but there's other stuff you you want to
own it
but it's it's not something that's first
nature yeah so that's my reflections and
you're letting me riff which is fun
because to do that means i have to pull
in
things that i can
verify with papers i read in data and
things are my impressions as a
psychologist of 66 years
or 66 years old i haven't been a
psychologist for six or six years i've
been on the planet for that long
i love it can we talk a bit about so you
you mentioned earlier in the
conversation the idea that we have there
there is happiness and joy to be found
within goal pursuit or you know what
what's that effect that seems to be
somewhat opposed to the
idea within for example mindfulness
meditationy spirituality type people
that says hey actually in fact all the
happiness is found in the present moment
and the more we kind of i guess striving
and desire equals suffering and all that
kind of stuff given that you're into
yoga you strike me and you've mentioned
meditation a few times you strike me as
having some understanding of that side
of things as well and i wonder how
it's are these two things really in
opposition like is is it like
what's what's the deal what's going on
there i guess no it's they're not an
opposition
but to reconcile this we have to embrace
the really difficult notion of a paradox
the opposite of one great truth is often
another great truth and i first
countered that by reading parker palmer
i really love he's a quaker
and he's written a wonderful book for
anybody who's into education the courage
to teach published back in 1999
wonderful book amazing human being but
if i think about it in terms of
meditation one of my favorite zen
stories in relation to procrastination
is about i think it was joshua
and so a new monk comes to the monastery
and meets the head monk and he said well
i'm here teach me
and the head monk looks at him and says
have you finished eating your rice
porridge like have you finished eating
your breakfast and he said yes then he
said then wash your bowl and at that
moment some of the stories go
the monk was enlightened
and it did the same to me it went over
me like a truck right yeah it's washing
my bowl
is this is it alan watts notion if this
is it
which is your idea of it's only found in
the present
but this notion of that
the happiness only comes from being in
the moment on the one hand and yet we're
human beings have are goal oriented
you've said this in some of your earlier
podcasts as well
that we have to lose the eye and in fact
in flow that's one of the experiences
where become less self-conscious it
doesn't mean myself is gone i'm still
the guy hitting the tennis ball to keep
on that one theme and i can be in a i
had been in a wonderful flow state
playing tennis that that was me tim
doing it but self was gone right i was
just in the action and
that's kind of captures how
yes joy can be found in the moment
but it goal pursuit is still part of
what it means to be human
and to become a meditator doesn't mean
become any any less human and that's the
paradoxical part of it
and if that's confusing a listener
then yeah who nobody isn't
right and that's where we spend time
studying the dharma
doing mindfulness meditation to try to
come to an understanding
that it's not just intellectual because
if you if you scratch the surface of
that intellectually you reject it but
you can come to understand it in a way
that uh resolves the paradox there i'll
leave it at that
but
because it's not an easy question to
answer yeah yeah i feel like i've got
lots of thoughts which are sort of
floating around my personal trainer
incidentally is super into meditation so
he and i just did it did a session two
days ago where he we we did
i guess it's hard to describe it's
always hard to describe meditation but
like after 20 minutes i felt like the
sense of calm and peace and serenity to
use that word that i just haven't felt
in a very long time or don't remember
ever potentially feeling before and then
i went on the sam harris's waking up app
and i was like oh wow he's got all the
allen wood stuff so that's now my
binge uh when i'm and driving oh and
then you can have a uh meditation for 20
minutes and i think you're going to lose
your mind right because all you're doing
is thinking and it's not going very well
and there's no calm at all and that's
meditation too and there's another form
of the paradox right and that it and
it's not the clinging this is what you'd
mention the idea of this notion of
identification or clinging and you can
think of that as well if i have a goal
then by definition am i clinging to it
no right you can have a goal but are you
are you identified with the goal are you
clinging to the goal that's different
right and
that's an important distinction we don't
become less human and less goal-oriented
but we can become
less identified with and and not be
clear
and you use the word
unsatisfactoriness dissatisfaction
dukkha
would arise because
it's inherent then if i cling to it and
i mean we can we can go on this forever
because it's just like the zen archery
thing when you aim you miss
right and and so again
these are things that are difficult to
understand just a strictly intellectual
level because you think well how you
ever hit anything if you don't eat like
what a ridiculous thing to say
yeah it sort of reminds me of the stoic
idea of preferred indifference that i
sometimes think about where it's like i
i'd really like my book to hate the new
york times list
but i mean but like i'm trying at the
same time i'm trying to convince myself
that i'm actually indifferent if it
doesn't as long as i've written a book
i'm personally proud of which is in my
control then hey you know the gods of
the new york times or whatever who cares
you're not indifferent to it and and
it's gonna be tough if it doesn't uh if
those listeners are interested in the
stoic approach william irvine you got to
read his stuff or listen to him
interview with sam he's got a series
there on the waking up back just on
stoicism
because it is a wonderful route to
happiness as well and if you haven't
already done it in your
own podcast i think it would be well
worth it yeah nice uh i will check that
out yeah i read willie marvin's uh the
guide to the good life which was the
first my first introduction to stoicism
and then discovered darren brown's work
and then ryan holidays and i still
haven't read the original
seneca and marcus aurelius and stuff but
it's always like
i would procrastinate from that because
well it's not procrastination because
it's not intentional uh it's like it's
just on the to-do list and it will be
done at some point
good that's a really good important
distinction
because
fascination but you never really made an
intention but then i could say to you
you know what it's still procrastination
because you have anemic intentions and
if you make an anemic intention it's
weak
here's an anemic intention i'm going to
do that on the weekend
when does the weekend start exactly when
does it end what is it exactly you're
going to do again you're going to do
that what do you mean by the whole thing
so
sometimes
we can let ourselves off the hook of
procrastination because we say well i
never really made the intention when not
making the intention is actually the act
of procrastination not that i'm accusing
you of that because i don't think you
need to read seneca or marcus aurelius
either
but
i just wanted to add that because it's
never so straightforward procrastination
is deeply subjective because we we alone
know our own intentions this brings us
very nicely to the thing that i was
going to talk to you about next which is
and again i'm going to zoom out a bit
and tell you what the sort of structure
of my book is tentatively because that's
sort of the angle that i'm approaching
this kind of based on the reading of
your work and piers's work and a few
other people whereby and actually i i
got this because i paid five thousand
dollars for a productivity coach at one
point and i was i was kind of curious
like hey what does the productivity
coach do and essentially what he did was
basically talk me through a method for a
goal setting
that actually worked worked really
effectively and it kind of got me
thinking that if if we think of let's
take a thing like i'm gonna i want to
improve my mandarin chinese for example
now you would say that the anemic
contention is oh yeah i'll just do that
on the weekend and i would agree that
like it's what the hell does that look
like oh i'll just learn mandarin on the
weekend is clearly never gonna happen
because like there's no plan it's not in
the schedule i don't know what i need to
do and i find that like often for me
when i'm whenever i'm struggling with
procrastination or what i think is
procrastination the first step is to
actually just stick the thing in the
schedule
and figure out what what specifically
the next action step actually is good
yeah and i find this a lot with students
when i'm teaching it's like oh i'm going
to study physiology tomorrow i'm like
okay hang on
firstly what time oh god okay fine uh
seven p seven until eight all right cool
now study physiology is never gonna
happen so like what specifically are you
gonna do it's like okay cool i'll read
chapter four okay cool now within
chapter four reading chapter four in
guided and horse physiology is never
gonna happen it's too long like do you
want to pick some questions and
guiding people through that thought
process results in okay fine
tomorrow at 7 pm i'm going to
do questions 8 till 13 in this book does
that kind of vibe with your experience
of solving helping solve procrastination
oh yeah i'm going to give you a big hug
from across the ocean here i've leaned a
lot in that book that you're reading on
peter goldbuster's work on
implementation intentions so there's
goal intentions we've spent a lot of
time talking about goals you just told
me you hired a personal trainer to help
you have better goals but it sounds like
the trainer also introduced you to
implementation intentions
and they're often framed and and
research shows they're best framed as in
situation x i'll do behavior y to
achieve sub goals zed
and and there's other research to show
that when we think about things in the
abstract they seem to belong to tomorrow
there's no sense of urgency to them and
when we think about things concretely
there they belong to today so you put
those two things together and it says
something about the way the human mind
works that we can well in a sense we can
borrow this notion of nudge right that
we
we move ourselves in the direction of
the way the mind works by saying i'm
gonna set a time and a specific behavior
i'm going to make it as concrete as
possible because concrete goals my brain
treats them differently
and
again
implementation intentions also help us
break habits or
establish new habits because we put the
cue for the action into the environment
and not rely on internal cues because
internal cues i've already got my habits
established and the example i constantly
use ali is how years ago i wasn't
flossing my teeth and my dentist told me
that i was developing problems with my
gums not surprisingly because of that
and for whatever reason i i brushed my
teeth
every day really habitually and i felt
it was an important health habit but i
resented flossing my teeth i didn't like
it and it was just too much of a bother
but i realized i had to do it
so i made an implementation intention
when i pick up my toothbrush because i
always did i will put the floss
on the counter when then
when then when i put down my toothbrush
i'll pick up my floss now some of your
listeners might be saying no you should
floss before you brush your teeth i got
there but i needed to bootstrap this
process by saying when then and then it
became a habit to have
there and then i also realized that
flossing actually feels good it wasn't
as aversive as i thought in fact i can't
imagine not flossing now and if i floss
every day now that doesn't mean that
there aren't some days when i'm tired
and a little little timmy little
six-year-old to me maybe even older than
that will say i don't feel like i don't
want to and i then
i have all sorts of other strategies i
go to like what's the next action just
pick up the floss like and or
more importantly than that going back to
our earlier discussion of meditation
mindfulness uh a buddhist mindset you
you name it parker palmer
because he said this i can have an
emotion
without being that emotion this is
another big personal mantra
yeah i'm having this emotion i don't
want to like i don't want to floss my
teeth i don't have to be that i can work
from other parts of my inner landscape
and my other part of my own landscape is
i have a health goal that's important to
me healthy gums and flossing a lot one
day a week you floss every day and then
i pick up the floss and i floss right
and in a sense then i'm not becoming
identified with a thought but to take it
back to where this part of our
conversation began
absolutely implementation intentions are
a great step towards reducing
procrastination but as peter galwitzer
makes clear even some of his papers in
the late 1990s when he was really
starting to roll this stuff out you have
to have a commitment to that goal or
it's not going to work right this no
trick or technique on its own will ever
make a difference if you're not
committed to the goal achievement these
tools serve goal achievement and if
you're not committed at that goal well
nothing magic's going to happen
yeah like i've so i'm i'm i'm in the in
the middle of teaching a live course
online helping people become youtubers
and
i often get a bunch of questions around
the the the tactics the implementations
and and stuff and especially when it's
kind of friends in real life asking for
from my advice around starting youtube
channels
and my thing always kind of starts with
okay i can
let's we can we can talk through it we
can work through it but like really
if you don't fundamentally want to do
this thing there is nothing i can say
that's going to make you do the thing so
let's tackle that part of the equation
first yeah and and the question becomes
why do you want to do this thing and
it's and it can come you can get finally
get down to an answer well i want to
write a bestseller that on the new york
times list right and i actually had a
fellow contact me because again i've
been very public with my research people
have emailed me from all over the world
and this one fellow i won't even name
the country just to keep it as anonymous
as possible it was on the other side of
the world said i want to write a book i
said well what's stopping you right it's
kind of the pressfield thing
and he had resistance and and it came
down to after a little bit of nudging
and questioning
that he said well i it's got to be a
bestseller it's got to be on the new
york times list i said well you can't
start there right
there's never a guarantee in life like
that way and then we often get into
and you and i ought to at some point in
this conversation deeply existential
issues right that we we can all we want
all sorts of things right but we're all
alive here in a certain set of
circumstances
and
you know the only non-renewable resource
that you and i have in life really is
time
and we don't even know how much we're
going to get and so in a sense your
focus on productivity and now our
discussion of procrastination
rests so much
that's kind of why i like oliver
berkman's new book you know 4 000 weeks
because he gets into this as well that
you know you got to be invested in where
you want to live your life this is not a
dress rehearsal
and let's go full circle back to ellen
watts this is it
this is it and it even goes back to your
notion of isn't joy found in the moment
yeah right now i'm really enjoying
myself talking with you right
you know why because i showed up
and so did you right and then when we
end this call
i'll have just as much fun packing for
the week ahead of me because why i'm
going to show up and get into that
yeah so there again a bit of a riff on
that but that's good i think it's
important to riff because all these
things will come together
yeah
yeah i think well one of the i find
myself almost automatically doing the
whole when then thing like i you know a
few a few months ago decided i was going
to try acro yoga which relies on
ridiculous hamstring or rather
just the ability to do an l-sit like
hamstring flexibility which i just don't
have at all i was like okay every day
i'm going to do 20 minutes of stretching
and it was never happening and i decided
you know what i've got an electric
toothbrush that buzzes every 30 seconds
so when i pick up my toothbrush and do
my teeth when i do the front the bottom
row i am hamstring stretching my left
leg when i do the top right hand
stretching my right leg on the bathtub
just because why not and now i just do
that almost as a matter i i almost feel
weird when i'm at a friend's house and
i'm like i'm brushing oh hang on yeah i
should be putting my leg up on the
bathtub and like doing a hamstring
stretch i feel like the more we can
the more at least for me the more i tie
actions to those things that i know i'm
going to be doing anyway the easier it
becomes to just do stuff yeah so but
there's also some theory and i'm i'm
blocking on the name right now
event segmentation theory psychology
when you think about the scripts and
schemas in our lives like you have a
bedtime script in a morning script and
you want to try to make these new habits
fit into something that
makes sense in the script and so for you
it was i can put my leg up on the tub
right but it's interesting just because
you make a win then
if you want to be really successful you
want to fine-tune that around making it
fit into an event that makes sense in
fact
some of peter goldwater's early work on
implementation intentions were that
women who were told by their doctors to
do breast exams self-breast exams when
they just made an intention
very few were doing it i can't remember
the exact number but it was very very
low maybe 50
and when they made an implementation
intention to do it when they got out of
the shower it went up to 100
partly because of the implementation
intention but i'd say partly because the
event segmentation theory that you put
it into a shower because you're already
naked and you're already touching
yourself with a towel so it's not a big
stretch to actually do the exam but if
you said let's do that
midway through making dinner like the
chances of you remembering that
uh are very slim right and and that's
the notion of prospective memory
prospective memory plays a role here and
again we can learn to outsource that and
again to ref a little further because
you love productivity so i i'd love to
show you my calendar my calendar
everything a whole day everything goes
on my calendar and i do
block scheduling
uh very effectively and i but i schedule
everything
and and i i can slide my calendar a day
if i get up a little later than expected
because i needed to but it's not just to
be more productive it's also
to do a an audit on my week i can and
it's all color-coded and i've i've seen
some of your calendars work too on your
podcast i think well yeah exactly that i
can take a glance in my week and say
when did i do exercise last week and did
i do enough and so it's very powerful
and that helps me too with i don't
prospective memory i think you talk
about them as type one type two and type
three sorts of things and so type two is
your task
but you're moving away from that yeah
yeah good that's good but but but we're
riffing around the same ideas right
these structures can help us
tools can help us but the tools are only
tools to get us where we want to go
again the buddhist would say you know
the raft got you to the other side of
the river you don't pick up the raft now
and start to carry it right
and so
you you might use a tool for a while and
then say that no i don't need this
anymore in fact it's in it getting in
the way there more roofing
let's say someone's listening to this
and
kind of
step one of my patent-pending
procrastination method is make a plan
and stick it in the calendar and stuff
let's say we've gotten to that point and
the thing of start my podcast or uh or
whatever the next action step of that or
you know do those questions from guyton
hall's medical physiology and at that
point it's like it's in it's in the
calendar
and
you're sitting down to do the thing and
then there is this other this this
more resistance and we are genuinely
procrastinating from the thing now i
feel this is where all the emotions come
in your i think your most famous quote
at least from all the stuff i've read is
procrastination is an emotional
regulation problem or emotional
dysregulation i wonder if you can riff
on that because i know that's
the whole thing yeah so we're all going
to get there like we all you know for
the outside we said we're goal-oriented
we're we maybe have enough insight to
put them in the calendar and so make a
very specific intention it's not anemic
it's quite an implementation intention
but we get there
and then something's happening inside of
us and because you've brought meditation
practice to the forefront i'm going to
add a name here and say tara brock
and tara
she loves the rain approach rain like
the rain coming down
she uses a little differently than other
people have in the past but i'll use it
both ways rain is an acronym for
recognize accept or allow inte
investigate interrogate and then she
says nurture and some people other
people will say non-identification
that last one we can talk about if you
want but so i think this is an important
technique to bring to
those moments when that resistance
starts first of all to recognize it yeah
i'm i'm resisting like i i intended to
go to my desk but this is quite real a
lot of us can feel that we our bodies
start to move away from the desk like
we're heading to the fridge now why am i
going to the fridge i say i'm hungry but
that's not why i'm going to the fridge
like i'm i'm excusing myself i i said i
was going to my desk so
i have to recognize that and then
allow it and and recognize the emotions
that are there can you label them
i'm feeling anxious
i'm i'm afraid it's just gonna not gonna
work out we haven't talked about this
yet and i should do it as an aside
perfectionism reels it's rear's ugly
head socially prescribed perfectionism
like i'm internalizing the values of
others some people call these
perfectionistic concerns as as opposed
to perfectionistic strivings so i i'm
having these thoughts of it won't be as
good as ally's you know allies is by my
coach for
creating this podcast and i can't create
something like him what's the point
right
i'm not going to get on the bestsellers
list what's the point of writing the
book well allow that
emotion and i can go back to parker
palmer's quote i can have that emotion
not be that emotion
and but then i can do that next step in
reign which is investigated where's this
coming from
and what does it mean
uh and and is this the only emotion i
can draw on here
right and and it's not right we can but
as soon as we start to name things
oftentimes they go poof
they go away
or
we start to bring into it and this is
where the the last the ant comes in for
nurture or non-identification and they
can they can naturally down stance
together even though tara doesn't always
do that
because non-identification is probably
in there anyhow with investigate
but here we have to accept our common
humanity you know here you and i are
talking we're different ages living in
different places
but we accept where there's a lot of
things that are common between us
because we're human beings we've got
light inside of us we've got darkness
inside of us we've got good things
happening we've got bad things happening
we've got strengths we got weaknesses we
do wonderful things we make mistakes and
so when we can accept that common
humanity and have some self-compassion
and recognize i can have these feelings
and not be these feelings
then that's the emotional work done
then i can go back to that wonderful
phrase we used earlier which is and
what's the next action and you can lay
on top of that implementation intentions
if you want making things concrete just
getting started and you see they have to
dance together if you don't do the
emotional work you're you're not going
to get to the cognitive work because
you're you're gone you know and
physiologically we can say yeah it's
amygdala hijack your whole olympic
system is screaming at you you know the
you're the six-year-old and you is alive
and well said get out of here we've
learned early in life that if you get
out of here you can get rid of these
you're gone
so you got to do them both yeah
i guess in in your experience what
experience plus research what are the
common emotional barriers that get in
people's ways we've kind of touched a
few of them the idea of perfectionism
potentially fear potentially anxiety
okay so alan blunt and i published a
paper way back and we were looking at
task aversiveness you know that task of
how aversive is something but the allen
and i
sat together brilliant guy and uh
said what the heck does that mean you
know aversiveness tastes different to
different people
and it probably is different for
different tasks and i won't get into all
the details but you invited me to talk
about research we actually looked at
tasks over time if you look at tasks
over time or projects over time there's
an inception phase like you know i might
write a book
and there's a planning phase you just
said i'm you know i've got these
chapters and this is what they're going
to be about and there's the action phase
and then there's this closure phase and
we'll leave the last part out we'll just
look at inception planning and action
and what alan did was he had people list
all their personal projects and have
them say where are you in
in these phases you know because you can
explain this to people oh it's just a
just an idea at this point it's
inception oh i'm actually actually
planning it no i'm working on this one
it's action
and then he had them rate them on
psychologically meaningful dimensions
this is brian little's work on personal
projects
brian little was at cambridge for quite
a while he was at carleton did his phd
at berkeley was at carleton he was my
mentor for many years i owe him so much
that way and then he was off to
cambridge because he was sharing things
more widely in harvard too quite a guy
and his work and has people take their
personal projects and rate them on
meaningful dimensions like and you've
heard me mention them some before
enjoyment stress difficulty but things
like value congruency outcome progress
all sorts of things that are
psychologically meaningful and alan put
in there as well task aversiveness how
aversive is this to you lo and behold
what we found is
that the nature of task aversiveness
changes depending on where you are in
the project in the inception and
planning phase if something generally
what we call lacked meaning
it was aversive to us but when we get
into the action phase it's not so much
of whether it's meaningful anymore it's
whether it's well structured do you know
how to do it
and so this notion of aversiveness has
many
flavors now the last part to my answer
is really more bang on to what you're
actually asking me which was so what are
these things
boredom frustration
difficulty resentment anxiety
fearfulness all those things are related
to task aversiveness
some of them depending on the phases of
the project i just explained and some of
them based on on our personality as well
because that's always present if i'm a
highly anxious person then anxiety might
be something that comes to them
for more things in terms of
interpersonal difficulties then
resentment and frustration may play a
role but all of these things you could
have any of them emerge and sometimes
they're a blend
ah this task is so boring i resent
having to do it it frustrates me no end
that my colleagues
don't want to do these things you see
that wicked blend that's there
well no matter what they are i have to
start to identify them learn from them
so why am i frustrated because i feel
like everyone's putting on me in the
team well maybe i got to do some work
there but right now i've got to do the
task and i guess once you've i i guess
applying kind of the rain method
recognize accept
yeah
except for allow yeah in investigate and
then nurture slash non-identification
or whatever whenever we find ourselves
struggling with
any one or more of these emotions just
running through that method i will
probably even just naming the thing just
recognizing yeah i don't want to do this
thing because i feel fear or anxiety all
right cool now i've named it i've taken
some of the power away from it and i can
just choose to do the thing regardless
of how i feel about it
and you could also investigate and say
so why do i feel anxious well because
this means so much to me like this is my
whole identity on the line and then you
can probe that a little bit and realize
first of all that it's pretty irrational
and you can deal with that and then
that's the common humanity
self-compassion part but it's also then
you recognize that this is really
important to me so rather than putting
it off today which is going to
jeopardize me i really need to work on
it right
we often talk about volitional skills or
i do because i say that procrastination
is a breakdown and volitional action
volition just another fancy word for
will like that you know this is my
voluntary willful behavior
one of the most important
volitional skills someone might have is
just being able to take a few deep
breaths see there's a lot of focus right
now on the vagus nerve for example and
you can do a deep dive in there if you
want i won't
but
calming down we've known this all our
lives and i've got a daughter who is
like her dad she can get quite worked up
and i have to say to her laurel breathe
let's just do this together
and even that one breath right because
you and i are
talking right now and you're a fast
talker you're even faster when you just
when you're doing solo
and and that just calmed me down and so
i would argue that even before you start
doing the rain technique
in fact there's a wonderful german
psychologist who talks about emotion
regulation training
or affect regulation training he's got a
book called art that's well worth
looking into affect regulation training
matthias burst
and
he he talks about deep breathing or you
know in some of your yoga classes or in
your mindfulness meditation doing a body
scan where you slowly just relax the
whole body
those things
work magic for you to be able to get
your focus back to do the task at hand
so but i'm a big believer in the
breathing because it's very portable
and two or three deep breaths and
you're changing your perspective again
yeah i just want to add that
nice that's great i i have not heard of
a lot of this stuff affect regulation
training i would definitely check that
out
okay so we've got the thing in our
calendar we've figured out our
implementation intention
we've found that there's some sort of
resistance holding us back we've done
the deep breathing thing we've gone
through rain right all right cool
i know i'm feeling anxiety and fear and
perfectionism about releasing this
podcast episode
but i'm gonna do the next action i'm
just gonna do it anyway
and see what happens earlier in the
conversation you mentioned that one of
your personal things that you almost
live by is just do the next action for
the yoga mat just get the mat out and
stand on it i wondered do you have any
other i guess tricks techniques
strategies for
getting over that like just that final
bit of hurdle where
it now just involves actually just doing
the thing or getting started with the
thing
well those two together are pretty much
bomb proof for me what's the next action
and
i can have an emotion without being an
emotion those two paired together are
very powerful for me you know i thought
you were going there with your question
which is you know you've you've put all
your ducks in a row to use another
overused metaphor
and you're right on the precipice of
doing it but there's still a great deal
of anxiety
this is where it goes back to this
deeply existential question and i can go
back to a really famous author by the
name of paul tillich
who in the 1950s wrote the famous book
the courage to be
deeply theological
but really deeply existential
and it is this affirmation of self that
is the courage to be affirming self in
the face of uncertainty
and and there's and he in his book he
describes but that's really what it's
going to come down to when i give talks
on procrastination i end up talking
about man's search for meaning victor
frankl right i can't help but because
not only like i turned a corner when i
read alan watts
as a young undergrad certainly man's
search for meaning did the same thing
for me deeply existential
and
you know
in his writing
he speaks of the fact that between the
stimulus and response there is the self
right that can make the choice there and
that courage to be that paul tillich
writes about it's the same idea at some
point
in all of this you can learn tips and
techniques and we can draw on modern
things down to a human issue
of getting on with our lives
and it's okay not to do the podcast it
really is it's to say you know what
i thought i was gonna do this i took the
workshop
valley but you know what it's not me
it's not value congruent for me
it doesn't feel
that i fit this i thought it would be
cool but maybe i was enticed by the
thought that some people go viral and
they make a lot of money
as opposed to i really like to share
stuff that i learn
and i'm really good at it and i i find a
flow moment in it and i find it really
creative so sometimes when we get into
that we realize we shouldn't do it and
it's okay to abandon it but you've got
to do that from a place of being
authentic
you know
authoring our own lives and when you get
to that moment procrastination
disappears
because when you're authoring your own
life and you mentioned this word earlier
in your first three chapters autonomy is
in there that when i feel autonomous and
when i'm authoring my own life this word
procrastination doesn't even exist
you you might remember it maybe you
don't because it and maybe they didn't
have this film in the uk do you remember
the the movie about the clown that the
physician who was a clown that healed
people no what was this i'm blocking on
the name but it'll come to me
robin williams starred in this movie
patch adams so patch adams was a
physician
who healed by making people laugh and
robin williams played him
and
a few years ago
the real patch adams the physician not
robin williams and i did an event
together i spoke in the morning he spoke
in the afternoon so i stuck around
because i wanted to beat patch adams uh
and he's not as funny as robin williams
but he he was um
an interesting man very intense very
political and at the end of his talk i
said to him so patch what do you think
about procrastination this notion of
procrastination now i'm channeling
patch here i'm not trying to be rude but
he said procrastination that's [ __ ]
put your pants on this morning or did
you try to put your pants on this
morning and at first i thought that was
a trivialization but in some ways it's
it's just truthful right that we can
make something so much bigger than they
are
and and if you as a physician you
probably know this because you'll you
unfortunately get to meet a lot of
people who are struggling with their own
mental health where putting pants on
isn't the trivial thing at all right
they don't want to get dressed they
don't feel they can get dressed they
can't they can't feed themselves we can
get to a place in life like that
and and in our the human continuum of
abilities we can look at tasks like oh
i'll try to do that. as soon as i hear
someone say that i think no
where's that courage to be going back to
po to tillich's idea where's your
self-affirmation
and to go back to that very deeply
zen perspective this is it
are you going to assert yourself it now
and if it's through the podcast then
you're going to do it but don't think
for a moment i always tell people and
this is why i think it'll be interesting
for you to reconcile pure steel equation
with my existential ramblings
to say that it comes down to one
engaging in his or her life
right his her their life
that you know these are deep choices
and and if you think you can move away
from that
around the things that you're really
procrastinating on that's just naive no
technique or trick is ever going to save
you
what was your experience discovering
alan watts and how did that change your
perspective
well
you know like many undergrads uh i i was
an undergrad let's go back even further
i was in undergrad back in the mid 70s
so 1974 i began university
and so
who did i read well i'd read nietzsche
of course and
and watts and that led me to other uh
radical zen and those sorts of things
took some courses that you know i think
it was george carlin who used to joke
you take just enough philosophy to screw
you up for the rest of your life right
and that's kind of what happened with
those things that you get introduced to
these big ideas not passing calculus or
learning the periodic table but oh my
goodness like
all of these ideas are out there as well
so
it was
revolutionary that way for me to be
introduced to ideas that did those
things and if you listen to someone like
sam harris and his waking up app and
he'll talk about
psychedelic use and changing
perspectives that way and so we've all
have life experiences that can forge
these these these parts of us that
realizes that life is more
than just making a living and to use an
overused phrase for some people it's
making a life but until you get there
you never really embrace autonomy and
authoring and that's why of course i
used to teach developmental psychology
and i had a section on it called midlife
crisis and it's those people who didn't
have any of these struggles of course
that hit the midlife crisis they go oh
geez you know this isn't that fulfilling
or rewarding
well it took you a while to get there
didn't it right and so it's well advised
in your 20s to do some of that grappling
and when you read some of these things
they are they bend your head because
when you say this is it you go this is
it really yeah this is it and you don't
even know how much of it you're going to
get um i guess final question i wanted
to ask you about is i'm not sure if i
if i if i
this was in your talk from nine years
ago which maybe means your kids are
older now but you
mentioned something somewhere that
you're a fairly old dad or words to that
effect
and i was curious as to
to what extent did having kids
give you one of those perspective shifts
that's often or sometimes people talk
about that oh the kid came into the
world and all of a sudden i realized
something
oh of course yeah so i'm a
self-described dinosaur dad it's
interesting because i i don't i haven't
ever put any videos of myself online or
any lectures although i've done many
lectures
invited lectures and things like that
and that that workshop people say i saw
your lecture i'm thinking what lecture i
never put it up but i see that my
university did
so that's and and my perspective is
refined since then in an important way
i'm much more proud of my talks but
that's true of everything right for
anyone so that's a bit of a airing some
of my own stuff when i say all that but
yes when i had children i actually
thought i was i pushed back hard on my
wife saying you know i think i passed
this i'm 50 years old and
we had to work hard at having our first
child uh for some fertility issues
something that many listeners will say
yeah we've been there too
but we won the lottery and had an in
vitro fertilization of work for our
daughter and then our son as many people
will find out with these stories just
decided to have every all systems are
running again so that we get that the
luck of having a son as well and so i
was an older dad i was established at
the university so i took time off and i
was mister mom for a while like i was
full-time
and my wife could get really frustrated
with that she said yeah i was miss mom
for a while too but no one celebrates
that the same way so what is how does it
change me well my daughter just got back
from camp yesterday she was away for a
month and i was just so anxiously
awaiting her return and
to see her step up just last night my
son and i went out to get some sushi for
her because she's been in the wilderness
canoe trip for a month and she hasn't
had these kind of foods and we wanted to
treat her and
and i'm in a truck car with my son
thinking i i don't know how to tell much
how much i love you i can't even put
into words
so
loving another human being like a child
is something that
i could never have experienced ahead of
time i've watched other people love
their kids but typically what we see is
when we're not parents is we see the
interactions in the
department stores which are outrageous
sometimes right you think the last thing
i want to do is that it's
it is life-changing for sure and i'm
glad i didn't miss it and it's the most
important thing i've ever done in my
life and i'm really happy to be a father
and i'm trying to do my best which then
you run face first into your one's own
incompetence right
and then we can get into the
the psychodynamic theories um of the
good enough parent it was actually the
good enough mother again we've named so
many people in this conversation and i'm
blocking on this psychotherapist name
but he's quite famous
exactly good for you yeah and so you
know that's influenced me in terms of
being the good enough dad
and and also as my wife would say don't
steal their struggle
and and i would bring from my
psychological background procrastinating
children because they don't learn to
self-regulate so i work very hard at
modeling self-regulation and that's a
little bit for
but all these things come out of
parenting as well and the last thing
i'll add is that my daughter you're
right she's older now she's 17 when this
episode or when this this conversation
is happening
and she in high school she was dominated
as
us beth's procrastinator i said laurel
there's a little bit of irony here i
hope you could see that
yeah there that's full stop tim this has
been a wonderful conversation thank you
so much for being so so gracious with
your time and expertise i'd love i'd
love to stay in touch would it be all
right if i email you further down the
line when my book is a little bit more
shaped just to get some feedback on the
procrastination stuff um oh i'd like
that to be honest with you because
i'm invested in it being if you're going
to include anything i've said and
invested in being correctly presented i
don't think you would misrepresent it
because i compliment you earlier on your
intellect i know you're good at what you
do
but it's nice to be able to just uh make
sure nothing's taken out of context
brilliant well thank you so much and if
you're ever in london would be great to
meet up and maybe have a part two of
this conversation in person
um i would love that in fact
a few years ago a fellow from the uk
emailed me and said
do you cancel i said no i don't counsel
and anyhow i said but i'd talk with you
and we have been talking together every
two weeks for two years and we've become
friends just around procrastination he
had his own struggles but i said i'm not
going to counsel you and i'm not going
to charge you he kept wanting to pay me
i said no we're meeting us two human
beings you've reached out to me because
you think i have something to offer you
let me offer it to you so i hope to meet
him face to face someday soon too so if
i come to uk i'll be hooking up with
both of you fantastic all right tim well
thank you so much for taking the time
all right all right have a great trip
we'll see you later take care all right
bye all right so that's it for this
week's episode of deep dive thank you so
much for watching or listening all the
links and resources that we mentioned in
the podcast are going to be linked down
in the video description or in the show
notes depending on where you're watching
or listening to this if you're listening
to this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the itunes
store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full hd or 4k on
youtube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching do hit the subscribe
button if you aren't already and i'll
see you next time bye